every girl I know help choose their
husband why am I forced to marry someone
I haven't even met he just moved here
from Bethlehem he's a good man from a
good family his name is Joseph I'm
securing your future
Mary what about my dream of becoming a
teacher like my father you are fortunate
anyone will have you with all your crazy
crazy ideas crazy
ideas you're the reason I have these
crazy ideas you put them into my head by
having me study these scriptures day
after day year after year because I did
not have a son to teach them
to so now you punish me for it you are a
girl you would be a wife not a teacher
as tradition
demands As You Wish
father oh
fig this isn't
fair Mary can we talk about
this I'm going to town Deborah
Rebecca we're going shopping that isn't
it's not what I said she needs to find
fabric for her patrol
[Music]
gown but I don't want to marry for Duty
I want to marry for
love most girls look forward to marriage
Love Takes Time to grow Mary like a
flower your husband might be handsome
exciting wonderful he might be a very
good dancer and if he's none of those
things he'll still be my husband Mary
you're getting married it's about to be
the best day of your life scary cuz
maybe
married means that I am kissing all my
dreams goodbye Divine institution a holy
Union One sure sign that you are blessed
or a life sentence of daily dependence
fering in yes steering until death marry
Mar married is the thing you do that's
very very very very good for you mar mar
marri makes two hearts into one happy
life engagement the invitation ceremony
celebration dreams are coming
true Mary Mary Mary Mary Mary is good
for
you it's good for
[Music]
it's
good it's good so holy
matrimony is marrying the wedding not
the man oh Mary you're so
contrary every knows that it's Conant
attention in someone else's Direction
your husband will have eyes for
you so romantic or just traumatic being
showered with so many precious juice
marry marry marry there something you do
that's very very very very good for you
mared mared married makes you hard to do
one happy
life keeping hous and making babies
going shopping all the daily chores are
I love
do mar mar mar mared it's good for
youed it's good for you it's good for
you
you it's good for
you it's not my decision but this is
tradition trusting that my family knows
best is this what I'm chosen for I
thought I was meant for more at least
you look so pretty in your
[Music]
PR you do very very very good for you
you're right mares two
hearts one
happy he may be short he may be har
getting back but Mar de he's chosen just
for
you Mary mar mar mar Mary it's good for
you Mary it's good for you maybe it's
good for you
you Mary it's good for
you you may be nervous May scared your
head is spinning everywhere I
[Music]
to good for me guess we'll
see I'm so
sorry
you're
welcome thank
you I'm an expert at
choosing what I mean is that I I know
how you choose
fruit I have many skills mhm it's nice
why are you telling this to
stranger I feel like we're already
friends no apparently I'm betrothed so I
really should get going
now yet here we
are
goodbye wait wait you haven't picked any
fruit I I don't think you heard what I
said choose one it'll be my gift to a
beautiful bride I don't accept gifts
from strangers strangers AR we pass
that this one's
perfect oh uh I didn't get your
name
Pig okay
who I hate
[Music]
donkeys
up up up up up
there
father oh ATI Potter my first
born returning from uh Rome Rome so
uh what do you want Oh Rome has ordered
us to conduct a
census King Herod I decree at the
command of our Lord and emperor Caesar
Augustus a sensus shall be taken
throughout the Roman Empire all citizens
shall return to their ancestral blah
blah blah blah
Rome
Rome father we we cannot just ignore
Caesar what as sensus will only anger
the
people you seem to have no problem
angering the people without Caesar's
help
wine should have them removed no no no
no they amuse me they're nice people
father I have concerns that Rome will
hear about this well I have concerns
that you don't know what it means to be
a king a king doesn't need to be loved
only obeyed un feared I live only
deserve my king not to be
one
[Laughter]
father father don't pretend you don't
want to be king everyone wants this
crown